hello everyone welcome to
cfar's virtual talk in our series
science is the exit strategy
for those of you who may be new to cfar
we are a global research organization
based in canada we convene extraordinary
minds to address
important questions facing science and
humanity
i'm rebecca finley and it is my pleasure
to be hosting today's talk on governance
tech and the pandemic and to explore the
questions what do the debates on contact
tracing apps in canada
and the uk tell us about the broader
policy
and governance questions related to ai
tech
data and novel technologies and how can
policymakers navigate these questions
effectively
and to do so i'm really delighted to
welcome
michael geist and carly kind michael
is a law professor at the university of
ottawa where he holds the canada
research
chair in internet and e-commerce law
he is the editor of several technology
law publications and an internationally
syndicated columnist on technology in
the law
the author of a popular blog on internet
and intellectual property law
and the host of his own podcast law
bytes of which
i should say i am a loyal subscriber and
i
hardly urge people to listen in he has
received numerous
international awards for his work and
has been appointed to the order of
ontario
carly kind is the director of the ada
loveless institute in the uk
it is an independent research and
deliberative body with a mission to
ensure data and
ai work for people and society
a human rights lawyer and leading
authority on the intersection of
technology policy and human rights
carly has advised industry government
and non-profit organizations on digital
rights privacy data protection and
corporate accountability
she's worked with the european
commission the council of europe and
many un
bodies the catalyst for today's
discussion with carly
and michael is cfar's report for
canada's chief science advisor dr mona
niemer
on society technology and ethics in a
pandemic
we were fortunate to assemble a
impressive and impressive group of
experts
both here in canada and internationally
to provide advice
to this report over a very few busy
weeks in april
chaired by ann mcclellan the group met
virtually several times published a
report for the chief science advisor and
laid out principles and implementation
guidelines for contact tracing apps
in canada michael was a member of the
expert advisory group that we brought
together to author the report
and carly was a member of the
international expert roundtable that
provided advice to the report
they have both been active in the public
debate on technology and covet and i'm
really
delighted that they can join us today
so we're going to get started but before
we do two
quick housekeeping notes uh first of all
language i just want to say that i tend
to use
contact tracing apps interchangeably
with risk exposure and
proximity notice apps and the many other
names that have been given to apps so i
appreciate the difference i was
looking today i think there's over 40
countries that have announced
their intent to either launch an app or
have launched an app already
so i just want to apologize in advance
that i tend to use contact tracing but i
appreciate that there are subtleties and
differences in the language
um and we can talk a little bit about
that and then secondly i just want to
say that today's session
will last up to 45 minutes if you have a
question
please submit it through the q a
function at the bottom of your screen
also we will be recording today's
session so you will be able to download
it
and share it next week so
michael and carly it's really great to
have you both
uh here um when we were chatting a
little bit
last week i shared with you that i had
recently done a talk with certain besley
who's an economist at
the london school of economics and a c4
fellow and we were talking just about
this
this question of providing policy advice
to government so experts and scientists
outside of government how do you do it
and
and he noted sort of two general
principles in the work that he did
first of all that experts can provide a
framing
or a framework within which policy
makers can get a sense of sort of the
pros and the cons and weigh the risks
and benefits
of what our complex policy decisions
that they themselves will need to take
uh and secondly uh that experts can
really sort of provide a long-term view
maybe sort of
try to give a big picture and a sense of
the of the potential implications of
what might have to be a rather hasty
policy decision so we talked a little
bit about sort of framing
the discussion around contact tracing
apps and novel technologies in a
pandemic sort of
within that within that context in terms
of what we were hoping
to accomplish today um so really sort of
sort of step back and said give some
sense of the bigger picture
take the longer term view and what might
be some policy questions
that emerge out of this discussion that
should be part of a broader
uh policy debate moving forward so um
to get started i think it would probably
be useful just to do some level setting
between what's happening in canada uh
and what's happening in the uk in terms
of the launch of contact tracing apps
and other
uh health identity technologies that are
emerging during the pandemic
michael can you sort of cast your eyes
back to
i don't know mid-march seems like a long
time ago
and give us a sense of where things are
today in canada
sure i'd be happy to and thanks again
for the invitation to uh
to participate in this so i mean i think
back in march we saw this mad rush
from many other countries i think some
even described it as its own virus
to try to come up with uh new
technologies particularly around what i
guess we'll describe as contact tracing
apps
the same was true in canada as we looked
at what was taking place elsewhere we
had many of our political leaders and
others that
started entertaining some of these
possibilities it was i think a fair
amount of that was taking place below
the radar screen
in canada so we didn't have any formal
announcements at least we didn't have
anything
formally announced very quickly but we
did have a whole series of
different initiatives where we had
sometimes some of the scientists in the
ai field in the tech field groups from
shopify for example
working on different potential solutions
we had privacy commissioners sort of pop
up and say you know we want to ensure
that you're considering some of these
kinds of issues
we had law and policy people who were
also expressing
some of their views and potential
concerns around some of these issues we
had the cfar group that you just
mentioned
so there was a lot of that kind of work
where we've moved i think over the last
couple of months is that at the
provincial level we had our first i
think
more full-scale experimentation with one
of these apps in alberta the ab
trace together app uh which went live in
early may so it's been around for
a couple of months now there's also been
a full review that was conducted by the
alberta
information and privacy commissioner
jill clayton uh you mentioned my podcast
and uh commissioner clayton appeared on
it
uh and i thought provided a really
interest some really interesting
insights both into some of the positive
benefits that
she saw with the app as well as how it
was rolled out but some of
also some of the lingering concerns for
the rest of the country at
a national level there is still i think
perhaps to some surprise a little bit of
uncertainty about what precisely we're
going to get i mean the latest
announcement uh is that the federal
government
is coming forward with an app it is
using some of the work that was done
uh through some people at shopify and
others and
ontario will be the first test grant
testing ground for this this was
supposed to have launched
several weeks ago it still has not
launched the canadian digital
service has has a beta test that is
ongoing
right now and it's closed for new new
participants but they are at least
testing something
uh and i think as recently as just
yesterday the logic reported that there
were several other provinces
that are anxious to become involved in
the
federal app so there is some amount of
momentum
for an app that the reality is the
virtually no canadians have had the
chance to use yet
it is late in terms of being made
available and i think there are some
lingering doubts
about effectiveness of apps given the
experience that we've seen elsewhere we
are a little bit
in a late mover advantage situation
where many others have
moved faster than we have we can i think
learn from some of those experiences and
one of the things that we've learned is
that
perhaps the enormous emphasis on apps
that we saw back in march was
somewhat misplaced great thank you and i
and i
and i want to come back on a number of
those points particularly on privacy so
so let's talk about that uh when we move
forward
carly i have to admit i've sort of lost
the thread in terms of what is happening
in the uk with with your app so i'm
really looking forward to hearing from
you in terms of where where things stand
it's like the set it's like we're in the
seventh season of lost or something
when it comes to the app in the uk so
you're forgiven for not having uh
followed the plot twists and turns
uh i mean lots of similarities with the
uk sorry with canada
but of course you know from the outside
some very different um
kind of fundamental differences between
the two jurisdictions
key they were central to which is the
kind of centralized nature of the health
system in the uk in the absence of the
federal system
um which means from the start this has
been a national initiative
and it's also useful to know that uh in
recent years
there's been a new body set up called
nhs x um
in the spacex tradition which uh you'll
be unsurprised to know has remit for
developing new technologies around the
health
system so the contact tracing up that
started being debated internally in
mid-march came out of nhsx
and was very much led by computer
scientists who were either
in the organization or affiliated with
it through the national center for data
science and ai which is called the alan
turing institute
and that's where lots of the early kind
of drive behind the contact racing up
in the uk came from but of course was
responding to this
kind of international movement or
building
momentum around in favor of contact
tracing apps which i think specifically
came out of singapore originally
um so in the uk the the plot twists and
turns have included
a big shift in government rhetoric from
talking about the app has been central
to
the pandemic response to over time
there being slightly muted government
statements or claims around the app so
the explicit language changed from uh
this is no longer the cake itself it's
the cherry on top of the cake and
and this is not kind of central to our
strategy
um and that really that really followed
um
as testing um was was undertaken there
was a testing
um of of the app on the isle of wight um
which is a kind of relatively closed
community of about 150 000
britons and as information came out
about
challenges that the testing was facing
the kind of government rhetoric was
scaled down quite a lot
um but the other big uh debate in the uk
context has been
the way the nhs decided to technically
architect the app
originally was to build a bespoke system
that was
about centralizing the data collected
through the app
in the hands of the nhs so that the nhs
could run its own
risk scoring algorithms off the data
collected around proximity
uh exposure and notification and
alert people according to up-to-date
evidence about
their understanding of particular local
outbreaks
so they chose to have this more
centralized system which required more
disclosure of data
of from individuals and um
uh differed considerably from the
decentralized approach that google and
apple
uh decided to develop building on the
work of
quite a number of researchers across
europe um and that became
quite a contentious decision on the part
of the nhs that they chose a centralized
rather
than a decentralized system now there
was certainly some
um arguments in favor of a centralized
system including that it would enable
more information to go into the hands of
public health authorities
but there were a number of technical
difficulties in rolling out the
centralized system that the nhs
developed
not least of which is that it simply
didn't really work on iphones because of
the
functionality of bluetooth needing to
overcome
the ios requirements so in the end the
nhs has been
forced into a corner around that and has
reverted to
using the google apple api so the
decentralized approach
the isle of wight test which was based
on the centralized version
has kind of gone into the annals of
history we're now
heading into phase two developing a
decentralized app
testing is apparently about to start um
and i think where you know as michael's
you know put quite a nice spin on it
about having a late mover advantage i
think that definitely applies
to the uk it doesn't seem like they're
in any rush to roll out the app now
i think it's probably fair that they've
been a little bit
burned by the first experience and um
there are some questions i think still
around the efficacy of the app
i think they are still convinced that
it's going to be a useful tool for them
um but perhaps the emphasis is more on
using it as a way to order
and return test results than necessarily
only around
exposure notification so it's kind of
expanding its remit i suppose at the
moment
well that's very interesting thanks
thanks very much um
okay so i'm gonna now i want to shift
and ask you michael a little bit more
about privacy but i want to do it within
this context of public trust because we
talked a lot about
the importance of public trust and both
in terms of
adoption of the technology but then
sustaining and monitoring and
um the technology moving forward talked
about a lot about that in our report
michael but
carly we picked up on that a lot out of
your report exit through the app store
which you had released probably about
two or three weeks before we did so
um that was a very useful so framing it
was in the public trust context
michael can you talk a little bit more
about your conversation with
the alberta information and privacy
commissioner around
privacy the privacy impact assessment
that she's done
where you think some of the uh remaining
concerns are from a privacy perspective
with an app
sure so i mean so i'm happy to talk a
bit about alberta because i think
there's some interesting things that
come out of that but i think more
broadly on a national level and i'll
come back to alberta
in a moment i think we're paying in
canada a bit of a price
for having not addressed some of the
privacy and data governance frameworks
that i think many have been calling
for an updating for many many years now
when it comes to this kind of issue
because
on the assumption that implementing and
using this app is going to be voluntary
we're not a country i think where we
would have a mandated requirement to
install this app
then you've got to be able to convince
the public both that
it i think provides some good but also
that it doesn't do any harm and that
you can trust both those that have
created the app those that may have
access to the app
as well as all the various broader
privacy and data
implications and so trust really is at
the core i think of
getting the kinds of adoption levels
that you need in order to have this
app reach any kind of effectiveness and
i think what we've seen in many
countries it is very difficult
to get to that point and we see more
broadly in society right now
people distrusting everything from
vaccines to the information they get on
kovid so are they really going to enjo
trust installing an app that by design
tracks where they are where they've been
as well as who they may have come into
contact with so it's a pretty high bar
to reach
and i think in canada we haven't
established the kinds of privacy
frameworks or at least updated
our privacy and governance frameworks to
be able i think to convince
people to pay attention to those kinds
of issues that we've got
kind of the regulatory wrapping around
this that they should be able to
trust this that's not to say that many
won't i think install these programs
anyway there's
a great deal of concern and many will
say that whatever some of my privacy
concerns are my health related concerns
are even greater and if
this app will help and if they can be
convinced that an app like this will
help i think many will say
it's worth the risk but i don't think
that's a choice that people really
should have to make i mean i think that
these are the kinds of issues that we
should have been addressing up until now
and still should be addressing and it is
successive governments it's not really a
political issue of liberal or
conservative i think it's successive
governments that have
in many ways really failed us to address
these issues such that when you start
peeling back the onion a little bit and
trying to identify well
what law applies what protections do i
have what are the penalties for misuse
it can be challenging to even even get
the kinds of answers you're looking for
at times because health is largely at
the provincial level
these are federal apps that may be
implemented at a provincial level
privacy is shared to a certain extent
and it depends a little bit whether or
not it's the private sector that's
gaining access or the government itself
so there are a lot of those kinds of
challenges i'll note one
a couple of things specific to the
alberta app which are things that we
ought to be thinking about and
the privacy commissioner there found
that they hadn't thought enough about
and those have to do in a sense with
exiting the app is this a hotel
california type of app where
you can check in but never leave and i
think there are
on there have been concerns people have
raised this really from the very
beginning
how do you ensure that once we hope this
pandemic finally comes to an end both
how do i exit using the app and how do
we ensure that
this app the apps become decommissioned
such that
the surveillance elements that are
really baked into these apps
aren't a legacy of kovit and i thought
that the when the private commissioner
in alberta talked a bit about this it
became clear that
there weren't good answers um in fact on
the technical side with the ability to
delete or stop using the app there were
challenges and so
you had to pay really close attention to
be able to stop using the app
altogether and she found that the health
authority in alberta hadn't really spent
much time
thinking about when when does this end
and how do we
decommission the app and while i mean at
a certain level that's understandable
people are running a thousand miles an
hour it feels like to try to
to deal with so many different issues
all at once
i think many in the privacy civil
liberties community
identified this as one of the core
concerns that we could not allow
surveillance style apps no matter how
valuable they might be and as we've
talked about the jury is still out on
that
but even assuming that they are valuable
given the current circumstance
we couldn't allow it to be the new
normal and we had to bake in those kinds
of considerations
about decommissioning the app from the
very outset and at least in the alberta
experience it's pretty clear that that
didn't happen
and we don't know enough yet at the
federal level but one would hope that at
least they've learned
that lesson in providing real clarity
about what happens not just
in terms of getting people to use the
app but stopping use of the app as well
great so in this question of um
you know public trust which is informed
by privacy as michael says but also in
terms of the terms of use and
uh around the app itself carly the ada
loveless institute has done some
really interesting work on public
deliberation
and consultation around technologies
uh particularly in response to covid i
love the name of the report it's titled
it's complicated
which which it is um can you talk
a little bit i think that would be a
really useful lesson in canada for us to
get some sense of
how you did that where you thought the
concerns were both in terms of privacy
but more broadly in terms of efficacy in
other areas as well
and and where you see that work going in
in terms of informing your work moving
forward
yeah so as an organization we use public
deliberation methodologies quite a lot
and by that i mean
uh essentially long public um
focus groups um which are also often
called mini publics or citizen juries
and citizen assemblies i'm not sure how
much this is part of the policy
discussion in canada but it's become a
very
popular thing to think about recently
and i think some of that responds to
kind of political realities around these
intractable issues such as for example
brexit there's this notion that you can
start to bring together very disparate
views on complicated issues through
this type of long-form public engagement
and we've been doing one prior to the
crisis on the use of facial recognition
and other types of biometrics
technologies
in the uk but during the crisis we
convened one of the first online citizen
juries or
citizen deliberation initiatives over
quite a rapid period so we did it
normally these can go for weeks or
months we did it over three weeks with
30 members of the public and essentially
what we do is we
we turn them into kind of lay experts on
a particular issue we bring together a
range of different
experts and um give the help then
present evidence to the citizens and
then the citizens deliberate
on certain questions in this case what
would it take to build public confidence
and trust in
a contact tracing app and other types of
technologies around covert
and it was a very uh interesting and in
illustrative experience it should i
should say it happened at the
against the backdrop of two um events
one was the
killing of george floyd and the um
momentum around black lives matter which
certainly has had an impact in the uk
and came at the same time as a very
important report which showed that
people from black and minority ethnic
backgrounds are twice as likely to die
of covert in the uk
than white people so the question of
inequalities and structural racism very
much rising up the agenda
during the period of this deliberation
and the other was a
slightly um nonsensical event in which a
key advisor to the prime minister
was found to be breaking lockdown rules
by driving to a castle in the north of
england it was very english uh example
uh involving a castle of course um and
that
that raised these big questions around
public trust and and you know does the
government expect us to continue to
comply with these quite onerous lockdown
rules
um so we saw interestingly how those
impacted the public's feeling around
trust in government-based technologies
um but broadly speaking we found that
actually privacy
and data protection weren't at the top
of people's lists
in terms of concerns around this app
although they certainly are there
in terms of a building block that's
required to build public trust
but first and foremost was that the
public wanted to see a transparent
evidence base around why this technology
should be used
and um they felt that that should be
shared transparently and they were
suspicious when any information was kept
from the public so
the isle of wight trial that i mentioned
uh earlier
there wasn't very much transparency
around that other than that that it was
happening and the public felt that that
was something that undermined
their trust um there was also a lot of
emphasis from the citizens on
independent assessment and review of the
technology so
they wanted to see independent ethics
boards and independent oversight
mechanisms
independent experts weighing in on
whether the choices being made were the
right ones
and they wanted to know it had been
tested by independent experts
the third element was around clarity on
the use of data to michael's point
they wanted to know when their data
would be deleted when would this app be
stopped
being used and so there we found kind of
support for the notion of
sunset clauses for example or you know
hard stops on some of this technology
and then finally they they were very
aware that we needed to consider the
system as a whole
so they were unwilling to consider these
trust around the particular technology
as separate from trust in the government
and trust in the system deploying the
technology
and that's where the questions about
this special advisor breaking lockdown
rules came up a lot so it wasn't only
do do you trust how you're using the app
it's but what about you know these
political figures around the up and
and do you trust the system in which
it's being embedded
um and so i think those those kind of
findings lend themselves and we're
working on something now lend themselves
to a
you know how to do it properly next time
um
type checklist because i think there are
some really um
concrete things that come out from that
in terms of what the government can do
to um to kind of be more transparent to
institute independent mechanisms
to make it clear when there are sunset
clauses and when data will stop being
used et cetera
that can actually increase public trust
that are separate too but on top of
data protection and privacy protections
as well
great so i mean i think those are all
the the questions right that have been
swirling in canada as well
around the apps and sort of trying to
get some understanding so i think that's
really important for us to learn from
the process that
you put into place and i want to come
back on one particular item you
mentioned michael and talk a little bit
to you about this notion of independent
oversight
this capacity for evaluation and
auditing by an independent body
who is that uh we talked a little bit
about it in the report i've heard there
should be a commissioner of sort of
covet contact tracing apps and some
jurisdictions are known but
what what do you think is the right way
to establish that independence within
all of the structures that are already
in place in canada but is there more
needed
that's a great question i mean i while
there are some who have proposed
specific commissioners and i think that
the experience in canada and the
prevailing view would be that
the same kind of independent oversight
that carly just mentioned would be
essential here too
my own view when you're moving as
quickly as you are if you can rely on an
existing structure that is trusted uh so
much the better
and so if i look at the experience in
alberta where
they had you know they had i think
really some really strong
technical chops in terms of being able
to take to look a little bit under the
hood at the app
uh and then take that and link it to
underlying or the the governance
framework and the legal framework to see
where things uh where where there were
potential issues i believe that our
federal privacy commissioner would have
many of the same kinds of
uh same same kinds of skill sets and
same kind of tools within the office
seems to me you mentioned mona nemer the
chief science giant's advisor
i think the government has some of those
people i think the privacy commissioner
operating as an independent agent
is probably best suited to be able to
deal with some of these issues
but i do think right now in canada we're
we're at a bit of it in a bit of a
dangerous
dangerous spot i mean we for months as
many canadians will know
had the prime minister come up with a
daily press conference which may have
confused a little bit
regular face time and press conferences
with actual transparency about what's
taking place
so there are a lot of announcements i
think there's less insight into what was
really taking place or how some of the
some of the decisions were being made
and i think frankly we're
seeing that being played out literally
today uh with some of the investigations
into we
and concerns around that particular
program and while there was this desire
to address
many issues all at the same time which
creates its own set of challenges
that really only enhances the need for
transparency about why decisions are
being made
establishing uh protocols that ensure
that science advisors and other experts
are able to
chime in and have an impact on what that
underlying policy looks like
and then ensuring that once those things
are rolled out
that you've got the independent
oversight built in i'm not sure that
we're i'm not convinced at this stage
that we've done that
all that well to be candid um we've put
together these various reports
it's a little bit of a black box i don't
know that we know
uh to a significant extent precisely how
that information has been used
and i'm not also sure that we have
established
as we are on the very on the cusp of
trying to roll this out
i'm not sure that we even know
necessarily how uh
what oversight mechanisms will be built
into the process either so
i think there are some lingering
concerns with respect to some of that
oversight
and i guess i i would conclude the
response to your question by saying that
if we take the position that we need to
create something from scratch to address
this issue
i think that that runs the risk of
creating an
even greater disconnect between having
something launched
and having the kind of oversight that
you need in place
ideally from day one or even before day
one because you want to ensure that
that oversight has played a role
throughout the development process
as well great carly i wanted to we've
been talking a little bit about trust
and trust in a government-produced
um technology but clearly these are
public private partnerships as well so
in canada with covet alert it will be
shopify and blackberry and then the
google
and apple api as well that will be part
of it so what do you think are the extra
steps
that policy makers need to ensure are
taken so that the public understands and
can evaluate
whether it's the procurement or the
roles of
private sector developers or firms that
may participate in the government
technology
yeah that's a great question i mean in
the uk that that hasn't been as relevant
for the contact tracing app because it's
been so firmly within the hands of the
nhs from the start
although i will say that in the public
deliberation work we did
there was great concern around um the
potential
cell sale of data to corporate entities
that was something that people wanted to
see would be protected
from the outset so and i think that
echoes what
other things we know pre-covered about
public trust in the uk
in different institutions so the nhs
enjoys by far and away the most amount
of public trust out of any british
institution
and i would say broadly speaking there's
greater trust in government than there
is in
uh companies in in the uk um
but in terms of government
procurement of tax systems more broadly
or
partnerships around technology providers
there has been another
um initiative launched during covert
which was
the establishment of what's called a
data store which is a kind of high-level
data
analytics platform which brings together
lots of disparate data sources within
the nhs to try to
keep track of resource allocation what
beds are free and which hospitals around
the country
etc and that project was
um launched with microsoft palantir
and a small ai company called faculty ai
um and the there's been quite a lot of
concern raised about that by privacy
civil liberties activists or
advocates sorry and others kind of
scrutinizing
the information government system
governance system
primarily because palantir was
awarded the contract um with a fee
of one pound and then the contract was
renewed for a million pounds
and um there was you know there was
obviously concerns there about
transparency procurement processes
um but also palantir's history as being
a defense contractor
and the kind of ethical considerations
which are very real
and substantial of a the british health
system contracting with an american
company that has
that background and i think that that
has raised more eyebrows and raised some
big questions about
what it looks like to procure technology
in particular in the health
system we've done some other citizen
juries work
around health data partnerships looking
at there has been some
quite prominent health data partnerships
in the uk recently with
between companies like deepmind and
google and health
and hospitals within the uk and a big
finding from that was that in terms of
what people
consider to be fair transparency is
incredibly important so they want to see
contracts in the public domain they want
to see open procurement processes
but also they want to see equitable
distribution of benefits from those
those partnerships and in particular and
i'm not sure if this is a uk specific
issue but i suspect that there are
similar questions in canada there are
geographical inequalities in the uk
um uh you know between the north and the
south in terms of
um deprivation and affluence and
opportunity
and jobs and the idea that health data
partnerships or technology partnerships
with with nhs trusts in different parts
of the country might benefit some people
more than
others was was a cause for concern so
this
notion that you need to have kind of a
fair playing field across the country
and that everybody should benefit
equally was an interesting finding from
that and i suspect
applies to other types of technology
development whether it be in health
system or other forms of
government use of technology
thank you so now i'm starting to get
some questions from the audience and
they're i have two questions and they're
they're similar because they both speak
to sort of the efficacy
of an app one in terms of
you know this with a level of public
public adoption required but also in
terms of its integration or
non-integration within the health
systems
data setting and otherwise would either
of you like to speak to either
of those points in terms of some of the
considerations that we both
both canada and the uk need to be
thinking about in terms of the
deployment
of apps and their actual efficacy and
uptake within the
within them within the population and
maybe
potentially michael also in terms of
mobility in canada
right across provinces and and otherwise
in terms of the population do you want
us to take a stab at that michael
sure i can start with just a couple of
comments you know i think studies have
indicated 60
or higher is sort of the number that
people often cite i don't know that
we've seen
many of any countries achieve that level
so it raises the question of how
effective some of these are
part of it i guess depends to come back
to your very your intro
where we're using contact tracing apps
as a sort of a
sort of as a as a broad term to cover a
number of different kinds of apps
uh and so you know in terms of the
linkage to health information in some
instances
these apps aren't necessarily designed
to do that at all i mean
and so one of the ways that there is a
hope to try to foster and gender greater
trust within the public
is to say the government will not have
access to this information this will be
information that
that you will have and so you will be
able to be notified effectively through
the app
as to whether or not you've had exposure
to someone and so
um may want to get a test yourself
quarantine and the like
um but that's not necessarily one that
links directly
into government data where there might
be trends or other sort of information
about
uh those that have this much less apps
that we've seen in some countries that
have been designed to try to enforce
quarantine about trying to
literally track where where people are
going in the lake so there are
a lot of different uses that we've seen
i think carly mentioned some other
potential uses that people are starting
to think about for those apps and one
would think even now
as we struggle with the issue of trying
to get our kids back to school
in just over a month people will say
well isn't there some role that these
apps can play in that regard long-term
care facilities of course
have been one of the biggest sources of
problems in canada
isn't there something technology can do
there so i think we see
the prospect of these apps morphing into
some of the kind of contact tracing that
depends on fairly high adoption rates
potentially into some other uses that
are perhaps
not quite so dependent on those numbers
quickly on the issue of
provincial issues this creates some real
thorny challenges from a canadian
perspective and so i mentioned the
alberta app
and we've got an ontario app i live in
ottawa and
quite literally from my office at the
university you can see
into quebec i mean it's just several
blocks
away in effect to hit to go to the
bridge and go into quebec and so the
idea that you'd have an app that works
on one side of the river but not on the
other side of the river it doesn't make
a ton of sense um given that there are
many people who commute each day
back and forth between the provinces for
work and otherwise at times when we're
not seemingly
mainly working from home and so how
effective is an app where it stops at
at a provincial border not really in
terms of the way people often live their
lives today
much less the desire to ensure that
canadians can freely move
in and around the country especially at
a time when international borders
raise some real issues so how we
overcome
what is areas traditionally of
provincial competence with
national standards or a national app is
an issue that we're still grappling with
you see that the
i guess the current approach is what
we're seeing which is let's try it out
in a province or perhaps two
or three and hope that it is
sufficiently effective that everybody
jumps on board a sort of network effect
when it comes to some of these apps
becomes in everybody's interest to adopt
uh roughly the same approach and you get
some of that interoperability
of data great currently thoughts on that
yeah i just wanted to share a resource
actually which i'm going to put in the
chat and i
i think attendees can access it but um
it links to a spreadsheet that we've
been keeping updated which tracks what
we know about
the deployment of contact tracing apps
in various countries around the world i
think we've got about 50 different
countries there
and it it goes to the information there
goes to some of the questions raised
here so
including around which countries are
using verified test data or diagnostic
data versus which country is using
self-reported data
which i do think is a is an important
distinction
um that has implications for how
effective the app's going to be
and the other one is the level of uptake
or penetration
in countries around the world i think
michael said earlier
we haven't seen very high levels of
uptake in any country certainly not
higher than 40
in any country and those countries that
have had at the higher end such as
australia iceland
and singapore have not reported any
um significant benefit from the contact
tracing up itself but rather have said
it needs to form part of a
manual contact tracing system
i think that even though i mean most
studies that have been done in the uk in
terms of
what people say they will do in terms of
um using the app
show that about 75 of people say they
will use an app
but in effect we know that that probably
doesn't
play out actually so the isle of wight
example being around 40
again that seems to be where it tops out
around the world
um but i think there is a in terms of
the efficacy there's a big
unknown still which is what do people
actually do when they get a notification
from an app saying you need to stay home
now for 14 days because you've been in
contact with someone
and i think that that um behavioral
question
you know it depends on so many factors
including their trust in the app
including
you know whether they think they were
wearing a mask at a time that they were
in touch with someone and therefore the
app is wrong whether they think other
people are gaming the app
um but also can they afford to stay home
from their job for two weeks does their
employer have some type of provision for
compliance with social isolation
managers etc etc so
those types of efficacy behavior
questions just haven't been
answered yet and we don't yet know from
international uh comparative experience
how that's playing out great so we have
about five minutes left so i want to
make sure that i just pause for a moment
and michael and carlene just ask you
we've touched on a number of different
potential policy areas whether it's
privacy framework
uh restricted use um in terms of the
data and the technology itself questions
of equity
and inclusion carly public engagement
and transparency harmonization and
mobility efficacy
are there i want to make sure are there
any other really important policy issues
that you think
maybe are not as well known or not as
focused on today that we need to be
thinking about as we take this question
forward and you each have about two
minutes to respond to that so i
apologize carly
i'll ask you first um
well i suppose there is a for me there's
a longer standing question which is what
does technology development in
government look like
going forward and what's the best
practice
actually for how government should
develop and use technology as part of
their policy making and i think that
the experience of the contact tracing up
in the uk at least has been
you know i think it will be studied for
years from a kind of
state craft and policy making
perspective because it
it was you know in some respects just
such a blunder
in in kind of many facets but also
brought out all these interesting
questions about
you know how does how does how does the
ideal or the hype around technology
drive policy making how does it
determine
the strategic choices we make and what
is what comes first the chicken on the
egg the
the policy or the technology and what is
the relationship between the two of
those
but also and this is a particular
interest in uh for me being someone who
works on
ethics and and data what um
what is the role of ethics boards ethic
advisory councils
in um in feeding into or overseeing the
development of a government technology
in particular when they those ethics
boards don't have any teeth
to stop the deployment or or ask
fundamental questions about it when they
can really only tinker at the edges so
i think there's a you know that so many
governments and and companies are now
paying lip service to
to ethics but what does it mean to put
it into practice
in the context of policy making at pace
um and technology development at pace
and i think then
the other uh just kind of issue we
haven't spoken about but it's worth
referencing is
um how do we deal with digital exclusion
in the context
of policy that relies on technology in
particular in the health sector so
in the uk around 20 of people don't use
smartphones if a policy
is specifically dependent on the use of
the smartphone how is that going to
exacerbate health inequalities and
health outcomes
for the most excluded and how do we
overcome that
fabulous thank you michael that was a
great answer carly
i i i i i guess i would choose to to
focus on
the issue of how do you move from
expertise within the broader public
and ensure that it somehow becomes part
of your policy development in other
words how do you do good science
policy and in canada we've had we had a
government for that for the last number
of years
from when i was elected really but a
great deal of emphasis on consultation
right it was
you know sometimes we felt that it was
almost too much consultation that that
almost every decision had to be widely
consulted yet
a lot of hearings yet to then tell
people what they heard and then perhaps
consult
on what they had said and sometimes
there was this frustration that we were
never moving beyond consultation into
uh actual policy development in this
instance there was no luxury to engage
in some of that kind of broad well what
do you think
you've got 90 days to let us know and i
think it's
in certain respects we have found
ourselves wanting in terms of trying to
be able to find
an effective policy development process
obviously at a moment of crisis but at a
time when there is the expertise
out there in the community a deep desire
to become actively engaged it was very
clear how many people were
just running to say here let me help and
i don't know that government had a good
way to be able to take that and process
it in an open and transparent way
such that we would get better outcomes
instead there was a little bit of who
you knew
is who they would traditionally be
talking to there was a lot of
talking up without a lot of clarity as
to whether or not it was being heard at
all
and as we've said we still don't even
know what the outcomes are necessarily
going to be and so
i think we have to coming out of this
recognize this won't be the last time we
face emergency situations and want to
try to tap into expertise and we've got
to be able to develop
better mechanisms to establish good
policy that don't
involve two three four year cycles for
how that takes place
but rather allow us to move much faster
in the way that
we would say some in the private sector
and others say they've got to be able to
react and move quickly
government has to be able to do that as
well
i think that's a perfect note to end it
on sort of where we started uh
that is the work that is our work to do
i think moving forward and
the two of you have been in leaders
in showing new ways in which uh
experts can and the public can speak and
inform policy moving forward so thank
you both
very much i think there were well over
15 questions that i didn't even get to
from the audience so i apologize to all
of the people
uh who had good questions uh obviously
there's more here for us to discuss
um but i really feel like we have
supercharged the discussion today
with carly and michael so thanks so much
um i also just want to take a minute to
thank fiona cunningham jackie sullivan
and wendy hall they were they're the
ones who made it
made it all happen here at cfar and to
encourage you all to visit our website
c4.ca to download the report we talked
about
uh to visit the ada levelist institute
website in the uk as well for many of
the good resources that carly spoke
about as well
uh you can find out at our website more
about this particular series but also
to pick up on that recording of the talk
if it's useful moving forward
thank you all again thank you michael
thank you carly be well everyone and
we'll talk soon
you